so
if you if you were to tell me a step
process would you say step number one
identify a nation that has a lot of
resources that we need that we can uh
monetize that they're not doing well
financially would you say that's step
number one
yes okay what's step number two step
number two is to send uh
somebody like me and an economic hitman
in to convince the president or the
minister of finance or
whoever is in control that they need to
accept a huge loan
from the world bank or the asian
development bank or the inter-american
development bank or
one of these organizations and use that
money to hire u.s
corporations to build the infrastructure
so
got so you do a study to
to show that if they invest let's say a
few billion dollars in today's terms
into building an electric system you
show that for the next
20 years the economy is going to grow at
a pretty pretty high rate
got it so so number one identify nation
number two go
send somebody like yourself a chief
economist aka
economic hitman to meet with the
ministry of finance or the pm
or the president whoever it is the main
leader and tell them
we can go to world bank and get a loan
for this much money and have american
business create infrastructure in your
country and that's going to create a lot
of jobs
and it's going to benefit you and in
that conversation that you're having
with them is that a forced conversation
or is that a butter
smooth amicable everyone's going to win
what kind of a conversation is that
you just asked the key question patrick
it's a so
you go in and you're on with a very
sophisticated report that your financial
experts the guys who worked for me they
you know we produced econometric models
fancy
you know mathematical models to show
how everything would benefit how much
industry would grow and how much
so on and so forth you go in and you
hand this to the president and you
basically say hey
mr president if you take this loan on
and it's going to really benefit you
and your family and all your friends
because your family and your friends
own the industries they own the banks
they own the commercialist
establishments and all of those are
going to benefit from infrastructure
oh and by the way our construction
companies are going to hire your
brother-in-law's firm
that happens to lay pipe and and your
sister
owns the john deere franchise we'll
we'll run a lot of john deere equipment
and
we'll pay top dollar for her we're not
going to try to negotiate her down we're
going to negotiate
her up in fact you're actually you end
up often
let's say paying two million dollars to
rent equipment that should only cost you
a million dollars
it's a bribe but it's a legal bribe
nobody can find you fault if you made a
lousy decision and paid too much
and practically nobody's gonna even look
but if they did it would they you know
you'd get out
so you all these ideas oh and
incidentally mr president
you and your all your ministers your
cabinet all of their children
are going to get scholar we're going to
help them get into colleges
my company was in boston a lot of good
colleges we had a lot of contacts we're
going to get them into the best colleges
in boston area and we're going to give
them full scholarships
and we're going to give them jobs during
christmas vacation and summer and when
they get out of college they have
guaranteed jobs with us
these are bribes but actually we went
out and we talked to the press
the boston globe the boston media and we
said hey you know we gave a million
dollars last year in scholarships to
kids from poor countries
we don't mention that those were the
kids who didn't need the scholarships
but so there were all these you know
they're very strict anti-corruption laws
in the united states in those days and i
guess they still are
but there's so many ways to get around
them and we we knew all those ways to
get around them so you go in and you
tell the president this
you stay so buy into this loan and he
says but
we should take on this huge debt and it
means we're going to have to take money
away from
education and social services and and
health care to pay the interest on the
debt and we say yes
but you're going to make a lot of money
you and your family so he knows that
he's doing something that's probably not
going to help his people but it's going
to help him
and then you also say but if you don't
choose to take the
the this uh if you don't choose to take
this deal
remember what happened to muhammad
mosaddy
in iran remember what happened to
salvador allende
in chile remember what happened to
arbenz and guatemala and ziem and
vietnam and lumumba in the congo
these are all presidents or prime
ministers
who refused to play the game and were
taken out in coups or assassinations
and so basically we're saying remember
there's people we call jackals
behind the scenes so basically i'm
saying hey mr president in this hand
i'm offering you a lot of money for you
and your friends
but in the if you choose not to take it
in this hand
i got a gun i didn't actually carry a
gun
but i knew those guys were basically cia
assets
behind me that had guns and you know the
classic case of the original
case was was kermit roosevelt who who
overthrew
prime minister mosidek in iran and
replaced him with the shah and that was
that set a precedent and these
presidents all know this
they know they know the history they
know they will be taken out if
so so what's the choice you know patrick
what would you do let me ask you when
you are saying it how are you saying it
to me like
i know the way you just said it right
now how would you say it to me if i'm
the shop iran and you're sitting with me
and you're telling me here's the options
let me
if you if you could role play with me
what would it be like how would you say
yeah first of all the shot we didn't we
didn't play quite that game because he
had plenty of money he didn't have to
take a loan
we were just trying to convince him that
he he ought to work with us rather than
the soviet union
that he ought to you know we wanted his
oil
and we were willing to help him
westernize his country and we didn't
want
he didn't want to go to the soviet roots
that was a little bit different
give me an example of somebody who you
did what yes
okay let's say i'm talking to you you're
you're you're the president of colombia
okay and and we want to get at your
resources there and
and i'm saying to you i'm showing you
all these fancy reports that show how
well your country's going to do and you
can show these reports to your press and
to your people you can convince your
people
that by taking on these loans you're
helping the country you're going to
build these big dams you're going to
build these big
electrical systems whatever so you get
all the material you need here and and
it's
usually a series of meetings maybe some
of them over lunch with a few cocktails
etc and
the president's maybe electing a little
and then you you just sort of suddenly
start talking about
you somehow you bring up the topic of
what happened recently to salvador
allende in chile
or what happened to albans and guatemala
depending on what part of the world
you're in you you talk about these
people
and you say you know isn't that a shame
and you talk a little bit about this
you know depending on the president
different presidents you you approach
differently
and that they get it i mean they know
the history it doesn't
you know these guys know what's going on
and their advisors know what's going on
and they're usually sitting there at the
meetings too some pretty smart advisors
who probably
you know been to business called the
same business schools that i went to and
so forth
and there everybody's you know i speak
spanish but
half most of the people in the room can
speak english too and they
they fit you know they get the same
background but i will say patrick and
i mentioned i talked in the book about
two presidents who did not play the game
uh democratically elected president of
ecuador jaime rodos
and the head of state of panama or
monterrijos
they had tremendous integrity they saw
what i was trying to do
and they didn't do it and
they they understood the dangers they
were taking and they talked about these
things
and both of them were were i believe
assassinated they were they were both
taken out and
there's two almost a little over two
months apart from each other in 1981
they were taken out in their private
planes
in ecuador first with jaime roldos his
private plane crashed
very suspicious circumstances and
less than three months later same thing
happened to omar torrijos in panama
these were the only two guys
that stood up to this that said we're
not buying these deals and in fact
made a big point uh public relations
they went up there and made very strong
statements and they set examples for the
world
and they were taken out in these plane
crashes
and although there was never a smoking
gun found
because in a plane crash the smoking gun
goes up in smoke
um plane crashes private plane crashes
are the best way to assassinate someone
if you ever
decide you want to do that and
because the evidence is gone but in the
case of
uh one of those cases jaime rodosa
the plane's engines were sent to a
laboratory in
in switzerland or sweden switzerland
um and they concluded that the plane had
not
crashed it had blown up in the air and
so
um and there was tremendous other
evidence there's tremendous evidence
that that points to these having been
assassinations
how much longer were those
assassinations after you sat down with
them
uh well with omar torrijos that i've
been sitting down with him
since mid 70s this happened in 81 so
this has gone
on he'd meanwhile negotiated the panama
canal treaty with jimmy carter
which turned the canal over to the
panamanians
at the end of the at the end of the
millennium
and rolos had only been president for a
couple of years
so i've been a fairly short period with
roldos
roaldos died first he was a lawyer he
was a college professor
he'd run on a on a campaign platform
of forcing the oil companies and that
was texaco from the united states
primarily to pay a fair share of its
profits
that it made from ecuadorian oil to the
ecuadorian people
it was a pretty reasonable thing and
they said if they don't do it i'm going
to nationalize them
and of course the oil companies didn't
like that any and i couldn't talk him
out of it
i couldn't talk him to take these deals
and he goes down in this plane crash
right after that plane crash happened
ronaldo
excuse me torijos got his family
together and and i i know some of the
members that were there
personally and said my brother heine
rodos of ecuador was just assassinated
by the cia and i'll be next probably
but he said you know don't worry about
it because
i've accomplished i've accomplished the
biggest thing that i wanted to
accomplish and that is i got the canal
back
in the hands and the canal zone back in
the hands of panamanians i successfully
negotiated that contract
so i'm ready to go and he stuck to his
guns
well that's a po that was a poor turner
phrase
he got taken out but very few presidents
had that kind of you get
guts or insanity you know i mean you
know and it still goes on i mean
presidents of these countries are in
very very
very difficult positions so so let me
ask you this so so if we go back to the
system number one
identify the nation that qualifies for
what you're looking for number two
go in and get a loan from a world bank
and create businesses there and jobs
and in return we're going to take care
of your kids we're going to put him at
harvard we're going to put him at brown
we're going to put them at columbia
we're going to put them at yale
full-ride scholarship all this other
stuff you're going to be fine and we're
going to pay you some kind of an income
number three if you don't here's what
could happen to you that happened to the
following six seven eight people
that's the business model is that pretty
accurate what the business model is
yes up until that point yes